every year on lindau island in germany
dozens of Nobel laureates come to meet
with hundreds of young scientists
it's rare for so many laureates to
gather like this so I'm taking the
opportunity to ask some big questions
about the state of medicine today to try
to get a picture of health
cancer it's a word that strikes fear
into our very hearts but just how
frightened should we really be some
scientists are suggesting that will more
and more be thinking of cancer as a
manageable illness but how far have we
really come we are here today for the
purpose of signing the cancer act of
1971 and I hope that in the years ahead
that we may look back on this day and
this action as being the most
significant action taking during this
administration in the early 70s
President Nixon declared a war on cancer
over 40 years on are we anywhere near
winning that war since Nixon's
declaration there have been some major
breakthroughs in the cancer story we're
going to reveal some of the most
significant in a time line stretching
from 1971 to today starting with tricky
dicky here Michael Bishop was crucial in
this story it's 25 years since you won
your prize and what progress have we
made in cancer in that time well we've
made extraordinary progress I still no
cure for cancer do you think we're
heading towards a cure are we well
there's not going to be a cure for
cancer although the genetic you of
cancer has unified the situation it's
still extraordinary variety of diseases
and each with its own genotype its own
family of damaged or malfunctioning
genes cancer is caused by the
uncontrolled rapid division of cells
which formed tumors why these cells
start to divide uncontrollably was
largely unknown until Michael Bishop
came along he looked inside the tumors
at DNA here he found mutated genes which
caused cells to divide uncontrollably he
called them anka genes I think the
examination of the genome proper remains
a forefront and cancer research we still
don't have the complete inventory
whether every type of cancer has its own
distinctive genetic fingerprint so I
think we're looking at an entirely new
tax
in the future which in turn will guide
therapy if and when we succeed in
targeting a sufficient number of the
genetic malfunctions with therapeutics
and so at the moment that the focus for
you is on understanding the disease in
order to later develop the therapeutics
is that the order that we should well
this this is a problem that you have to
understand the underpinnings that's why
we made so little progress over the last
50 60 years we didn't understand the
disease so all the therapeutics were
based on one simple principle cancer
cells ostensibly but not always grow
faster than normal cells and so will
kill the dividing cells any poison that
will kill the lighting cells ought to
selectively kill cancer cells well yes
and no we know that the toxic effects of
chemotherapy classical chemotherapy are
can be horrendous and it's because
normal cells are still dividing in our
bone marrow and our gastrointestinal
tract even in our brain to some extent
and all of that was necessary because we
simply did not understand the disease
now at least we know the fundamental
underpinning and that is the malfunction
of genes whatever the causes and there
are many causes and we don't know most
of them and that's one of our
fundamental problems actually but in any
event we do now have a fundamental
understanding we know where to look
Bishop published the discovery of the
first human oncogene in 1979 and this
work would lead to his Nobel Prize in
1989 scientists understanding of cancer
had made a huge leap forward we could
now see it as a problem of gene
expression of mutation in core functions
within our bodies but Bishop emphasized
that we were still largely in the dark
about the causes of these mutations but
there are some causes of cancers which
have been discovered the impact of
smoking and ultraviolet radiation were
becoming clearer and in 1983 work would
be published that would prove another
long-held theory that in some cases
infectious agents like viruses are to
blame
that discovery was made by harold zur
hausen have you ever considered
collaborating with Michael Bishop
Michael Bishop is working in a different
field and we do they even working on a
different philosophy both of us he of
course stated cancers derived from an
imbalance between oncogenes and tumor
suppressor genes viruses and infectious
agents are disturbing this beautiful
picture when did you first realize that
a virus could be causing cancers I
speculated of it as in student times
must have been in 1958-59 or so that I
became a wealth of fact that some pages
or infecting bacteria stay latent Lee in
those bacteria and modify the properties
and that really triggered the idea in my
mind similarly genome of a virus has
taken up by a human cell and that the
transforms the seven to cancel so it was
a very naive idea basically as it turns
out it was a fairly different idea for
the cancer community if you like how do
people react some people and even some
famous people became quite skeptical
well infectious agents at all could play
a role in human cancer but basically I
was sticking to it completely zur hausen
discovered the link between human
papillomavirus HPV and cervical cancer
in 1983 it provided a new avenue of
research into cancer prevention and
treatment vaccines by searching for a
vaccine for HPV maybe we could prevent
people ever getting cervical cancer I
wondered if this could also provide hope
for tackling other types of cancer no I
I don't think see we're talking about
vaccines against known causes that are
viruses are all cancers caused by
viruses we have absolutely no reason to
believe that i'm not talking about
cancer vaccines i'm talking about
vaccines against viruses that cause
cancer but to the extent that there are
tumors that are not caused by infectious
agents vaccines i think
irrelevant the idea that we could
vaccinate against a cancer cell is
totally undermined by the fact that we
now know more than ever by virtue of
genomic evidence that for example breast
cancer does not have a single defining
tumor antigen it's interesting you
mentioned breast cancer that's one
example where there's been very very
highly publicized genetic testing for
some strains of breast cancer do you
think that's that's one of the ways we
should be looking for the future well
though the genetic testing for breast
cancer involves just two genes that
create a powerful predisposition to the
disease the genetic testing in that
instance is to evaluate the members of
the family for their risk that kind of
strongly inherited predisposition to
cancer based on a single gene defect
their genetic testing is a reality but
the concept that we could define more
subtle susceptibilities is still on the
table what we know for sure is that they
are polygenic to the point of impossible
complexity many genetic variants each
were the miniscule impact on
predisposition whether that will ever
translate into widespread population
screening i think is totally up in the
air at the moment because we haven't
solved the complexities of it the BRCA
genes or Braca genes implicated in
breast cancer were identified in 1994
they were the next step in understanding
screening for and preventing cancers
working with cancer is clearly
complicated but not just because of the
biology I met two young researchers both
clinicians who were driven by their
personal experience what's it like to
work with patients who are facing these
cancers be they on the treatable side or
less treatable I find it very
challenging and challenging because
there are a lot of cancers that you can
treat and as you just like that you
cannot treat my motivation itself to
become a physician was initially because
we had cancer run within the family and
amount my close friends instead of
grieving for years and investing all
this energy into this
into the sadness I just decided that I
couldn't change this situation anymore
so I just made this decision for myself
and said okay I want to tunnel all of
this energy into research and make a
difference even if it's just one single
person at least I could change the life
for this one single person because I
realized going through this entire
battle that cancer does not only affect
the patient it's a disease that affects
the entire family and friends around it
and it really is a disease with no
boundaries but what about for the
campuses that are not currently
treatable being a physician is also my
job to comfort the patient and knowing
as best as possible about the disease is
important because then I know where the
limits are and making the rest of his
life as pain-free as possible should be
all of our goals many cancers remain
poorly understood and are often fatal
but there are some cancers where our
understanding is growing and there are
success stories what do you think will
cancer ever become a treatable long-term
but quite minor disease coming from the
standpoint of someone who works on
chronic myeloid leukemia which is a kind
of blood cancer in the past can our
patients used to progress to the acute
plastic phase of the disease where they
were you know parish within months but
these days are with the invention of a
tyrosine kinase inhibitor cut imagine it
they can expect to live you know long
relatively normal lives if they just pop
a pill every day the drug imatinib
deactivates an enzyme which is only
found in the cancer cells of chronic
myeloid leukemia patients this stops the
cancer cells growing and can completely
control this disease it was the first
time that such an effective and targeted
cancer treatment had been discovered
these days the vast majority of those
suffering from childhood leukemias
survived them in the process of my
research you know I I have to look
through patient records on a computer
and its really heartening to see that
you know these patients have record
spending you know tens of years because
simply because they have had a chance to
be treated you know in case of chronic
myeloid leukemia chronic myeloid
leukemia is not the
only success story in 2006 heralds the
housings work led to the discovery and
implementation of a vaccine against
human papillomavirus and according to
him the impact could be huge but if we
could get the HPV vaccine widely
available would that lead to an
eradication of the cancer it could it
could lead indeed to eradication of
let's say at least those cancers which
are due to the agents of change the
vaccine then we really have a chance to
eradicate these types of infection but
only if we vaccinate globally and is
that a model that could be rolled out
for other types of cancer that vaccinate
and then eradicate we see now that the
board slightly more than twenty percent
of the global cancer incidence is linked
to infections and it is in my opinion is
likely as this percentage is increasing
in the future for instance it's clearly
worthwhile to investigate colon cancer
to investigate human breast cancer some
childhood cancers like acute lymphatic
leukemia brain tumors and also
neuroblastomas for potential role of
infectious agents in them shortly after
the rollout of the worldwide HPV vaccine
campaigns so heusen won a Nobel Prize
for his work in 2008 all this is just a
tiny snapshot of the progress which
we've made in cancer research in the
last 40 years Nixon may have been over
optimistic but there has been success in
some areas in others less so the real
question is where next we all know
somebody who's been affected by cancer
and it would seem that progress is being
made exciting is happening we know so
much more than we used to know but why
aren't we closer to being able to fix it
well we are closer we're just not there
yet and if you compare what we know
about the disease now to what I knew a
quarter of a century go it's just
logarithmically different and in one
generation of scientists we know how it
operates we don't know all its causes
but we know what those causes
precipitate in the cancer
now it has totally transformed our
approach to taxonomy of cancer it's in
the process of transforming our approach
to Diagnostics to early detection but
we're not finished by far because it's a
difficult complex problem and it has
multiple facets every organ systems
tumor is different so it's in a way
clearly a complicated disease but it's
not unresolvable but we can only prevent
these diseases if we understand fully
the type of a way and mechanism by which
the diseases emerging from the
conversations that I've had here I've
realized just how much progress science
has made in understanding and treating
cancer but that knowledge has also
revealed just how complex and diverse
cancers are and just how far there still
is to go
you
we're here in lindale with 37 Nobel
prize-winning scientist 600 young
researchers 12 of them sponsored by Mars
and people want to hear all about the
science that Mars has been doing well
the great thing about coming to lindale
is that we get to spend time with
sciences rock stars you aware that
you're in the presence of greatness and
the more that we can find ways of
engaging some of the finest minds in the
world to helping us solve some of these
grand challenges and then there's got to
be some great stuff in
one of the things we do is we like to
have a lunch where we basically spend
time with the young scientists that
we've sponsored to come here and tell
them a little bit about the kind of
company that we are kind of work that we
do and why we passionately believe that
these great scientists should consider
coming to a company like Mars for a
lifetime career in fun science that will
make the world a better place best part
really is that you get to actually meet
these young scientists who will look at
you in the eye and say this is the best
week of my life
it is Sigma the Nobel laureate and have
a conversation that is a gift so we have
a science breakfast which is the
opportunity for us to host the
discussion around a very meaningful area
of research of healthy aging so we have
Liz Blackburn who won a Nobel Prize in
this field and we put her together with
a group of young scientist in the forum
facilitated by ourselves let's think
about the huge amount of years that
human lives are right so I made little
scale bar for you on this high-tech
thing here this is a time scale what's
the maximum life span over a worm it
goes from here to here right of a fruit
fly from here to here and now things get
a bit better okay let's go all the way
out to a mouse all right keep going keep
going okay we've got up to kindergarten
we've got decades and decades of life so
the science breakfasts are always great
fun highly interactive and a really good
way to have meaningful debate in an area
of public interest but also interest to
ourselves we're in middle age here so
maybe somebody's getting some diabetes
now I mean that's the thing it's not
just your life span there's perhaps
years of living with chronic disease I
think you get the point right I'm just
constantly struck by how we have to be
thinking in terms of enormous timescales
that these things are the world is going
to be facing an aging population we're
all going to get older and there's going
to be a lot more of us who are old how
do we deal with that helping young
scientists realize that they can work
with somebody and realize that these are
problems that the world has to solve and
business and science can do it together
I think the private sector can play a
real role because this sort of research
that can be done by a company that isn't
necessarily related to just the
quarterly bottom line is the kind of
research that's complementary to what
governments can find and I think Mars is
a good example of that so we got 37
Nobel laureates here and just over 600
young scientists and if we can play our
role in catalyzing some of the magic
happening between those two groups of
people then we go away very happy
you